I'm Bob wolven I'm an associate
university librarian here at Columbia
and sort of your master of ceremonies
for at least part of the day I want to
say how pleased we are that so many
people were able to come today for this
discussion and exploration of tools and
collaborations around web archiving it's
it's just about a little over three
years now since Columbia convened
another meeting elsewhere on campus to
which we rather grandiosely call the
summit on web archiving to bring
together we had about some three dozen
people sitting around talking about the
issues and challenges being faced by the
people working in this field and trying
to begin to think about ways to address
those issues and meet those challenges
in in many ways that that i'll come back
to into little detail a bit later this
meeting is an outgrowth of that that
earlier session many of the things we'll
be talking about today are relevant and
responsive to the issues and the
challenges we talked about then but a
lot has happened in three years as I was
just talking with with Jim Neal you know
this field has changed good deal with a
rather short period of time and
undoubtedly still has a long way to go
the changes are reflected in the the
size and nature of the audience here
today we have researchers scholars
developers as librarians technologists
so I rather diverse group of people with
a rather group of interests around this
area the program today has two broad
themes reflected in the two words tools
and and and collaborations the tools
being developed to facilitate the
process of web archiving the the success
of that process the results and the
collaborations that we are going to need
to to do this at a larger scale and to
make it work to some extent the choice
of those themes is self-serving that
they correspond to work that's going on
here in colombia's own web archiving
program and two major components of
grant that we have from the Andrew W
mellon Foundation which is now in its
third and final year but I hope in this
case self-interest correlates with a lot
of other people's interests we think
that this is a reflective of what's
going on in the field in general and
that many people will find some of these
things of interest as we explore them
during the day at first appearance the
two themes tools and collaborations are
quite different and engage different
people and that's reflected again in the
makeup of the audience today but it's
also if there's one thing I can say it's
a salient thing to say about web
archiving is as it relates to libraries
nobody quite knows where it fits it has
aspects of collection development of
preservation of information technology
of institutional archiving special
collections and so our hope is that the
the ideas we talk about today and the
projects and activities that are going
on we'll find something that resonates
with everyone here and maybe point out
and even create some connections that
may not be obvious so before introducing
our first speaker for the day just when
I go through some of the the logistics I
trust most of you by now have figured
out how to connect to Wi-Fi you've got a
choice of venue Rome or the Columbia
network if you just look at Columbia
University the non secured network you
should be able to get in with no
problems many of you have probably also
found the bathrooms but in any case
they're over there you can get to the
neither through the drawer of the room
on this floor we are videotaping and
recording the session today so when we
get to questions and answers we will
have microphones that that wireless
microphones circulating through the
audience and we'd ask if possible that
you use the microphones just so that
your question gets recorded as well we
do have a hashtag which is up there also
you'll note we I didn't want people we
talked about this last night with the
speakers we didn't want people staring
out the windows all day so we've put up
the view of New York City there
substitute for looking at the we will
have lunch in this room and following
lunch we have arranged a few lightning
talks of people who have quick things
they want to talk about here and if
anyone would like to give a lightning
talk and hasn't said so yet see me or
one of the organizers during the course
of the morning there will be his
reception at the end of the day which
will be in the cafeteria well in the
cafe on the sixth floor will say more
about that when the time comes and I
hope many of you will be able to stay
for that and finally I do want to to
thank a number of people it's always as
jim was saying it's always risky
thanking people because you never do
believe someone out and hit yourself in
the head later but I'm going to do my
best anyway first of all I want to thank
the people on the steering committee
here at Columbia who steer our web
archiving program it also helped to
organize and really did the bulk of the
work organizing this event boy I should
have written their names down but I'm
going to do it by memory should enable
new member Steven Davis Pamela Graham
Kate Harcourt danapur Ichi and Alex
Thurman especially analysts and Anna who
really did the bulk of the work for for
organizing this if I could just ask you
to stand for Renee the five
I wasn't asking you to applaud them I'm
asking you to memorize their faces so
that if you if you have any questions or
problems see see one of them or me
during the course of the day four of our
other staff have very graciously
volunteered to help out with the
registration table with the microphones
and so forth so you'll see them during
the course of the day too that's nyeem
actor ryan grin kate birch and bill
hamilton and you'll notice them i
especially want to thank the Andrew W
mellon foundation for making our program
possible and for the funding that a lot
of the activity that will be talking
about today and I'll say a bit more
about that in a bit too but first and
foremost let me introduce as our first
speaker today to introduce this session
kicked off Jim Neal the University
Librarian emeritus here at Columbia I'm
sure many of you know Jim from his long
and illustrious career working in
libraries and leading areas of
information policy and intellectual
property and many other things and it by
prearrangement I'm not going to try to
go through all of his his
accomplishments but i do want to mention
why it's so appropriate that he be
leading off this session it's really
thanks to Jim that we started web
archiving here at Columbia he really was
an inspiration for that and a very early
advocate of the role of libraries and
the importance of web archiving for
libraries and for scholarship and so I
will let him say more about why that's
the case
thanks Bob as University Librarian I was
very used to being trotted in front of
conferences on campus to provide that
proverbial administrative welcome and
greeting and so I was pleased when Bob
asked me to offer a full three hour
morning workshop at the session but a
couple weeks ago he said no no we don't
have enough time Jim you're going to
have to cut that down to about an hour
keynote and I said okay I can do that
and he said oh by the way Jim we're
going to have to make it even shorter
we're going to give you about 30 minutes
to do your thing and then last night he
called me says Jim you got five minutes
to say what you want to do but I'm going
to I'm going to stick to my 30 minutes
and share some ideas and perspectives
with you I'd like to sort of dedicate my
remarks today to a extraordinary
colleague and friend Dan hazen from
Harvard University who many of us worked
with for many many years a remarkable
remarkably smart thoughtful provocative
guy and he passed recently and so let's
keep him in mind as we think about these
issues today so I've noticed over the
last several years that my public
presentations have become much more
alarmist and much more strident I have
subscribed to the Emerson adage
sometimes a screen is better than a
thesis much of my recent angst has
focused on our alarming collective
failure to capture organize and preserve
long-term the availability and usability
of the bourne scientific and cultural
record for my remarks today I draw from
a recent presentation at the OCLC
regional council meeting in Florence and
from a brief paper I published in the
may 2015 american libraries my lens is
the university and the library
we would all acknowledge that the world
is producing vast amounts of born
digital materials clearly the volume
complexity and dynamism of this content
transcend our traditional information
practices the Columbia libraries along
with a number of players around us and
the world began to explore this
challenge a few years ago with generous
support from the mellon Foundation we
sought to examine and evaluate the
policy workflow legal governance
financial and service service frameworks
for collecting and archiving open web
content websites and documents are the
tip of the born digital condition born
digital content comes in an ever
expanding array of forms and formats
consider just the following examples
published and licensed work such as a
journalist ebooks a video audio from
commercial and trade sources but the
explosion from the growing array of
independent publishers and distributors
and the revolution in self-publishing
and self distribution we have no idea
what's going on in those environments
the output of eager meant online
learning and training materials research
data from universities and corporations
social media and all of its wonderful
expressions electronic archives that
come with personal and organizational
papers records of organizations
including email manuscripts business
papers and financial information
pictorial images spatial data and
longitudinal observations software
applications both proprietary and open
source video games medical data with the
inherent challenges of patient privacy
live feeds like RSS and news information
from around the world visualizations and
simulations interoperable meta
data and so on and so on with so many
new things that will grow in intensity
and intricacy I argue that in many ways
we are dealing with an issue of
integrity the coherence and rectitude of
scholarship i believe is at risk we all
must adhere to a code and standard of
values maintaining human records as
complete unimpaired and undivided as
possible the ability to consult the
evidence and sources used by researchers
and authors will be lost if these
digital records are not available the
ability to investigate the history and
current state of the world across all
disciplines will be compromised if born
digital materials are gone or changed
and the ability to access and use the
sources of record will be difficult if
they are deposited and dispersed in
multiple and disparate sites let me
share some some scenarios with you let's
consider a scholar who prepares a major
research paper and it is published in a
prestigious Journal the paper includes
in its reference several born digital
items which are critical to the
arguments of the author another
researcher reads the paper in that
journal and disagrees with the
conclusions and wants to consult the
evidence however the sources are no
longer retrievable and cannot be
reviewed the links are broken on the
sites they have been taken down or they
have been significantly changed is this
an issue of scholarly integrity or this
second scenario a researcher on the
debate over climate change once to
locate and review the websites and other
reports of organizations government
agencies and individuals that have
presented data arguments and
recommendations over the past decade the
researcher finds that many of these
sources are no longer available and thus
cannot be consulted thus making it
difficult
if not impossible for the research
project to proceed is this an issue of
scholarly integrity or this third
scenario a researcher completes an
important research study and it is
accepted by a leading journal in the
field the paper and the research data
supporting the project will be available
through the publisher repository because
of the agreement that the author
negotiated with the publisher the
researcher is allowed to make the work
available in various other open access
sites so the work also appears in a
disciplinary repository in an
institutional repository at the
researchers institution in a special
academic department repository in a
research data repository in a government
repository because of the grant that
funded the project on his personal
website on the teaching course website
of the researcher in a national
repository and so on which version of
this work will be discovered used cited
preserved without changes is this
condition of repository chaos an issue
of scholarly integrity the collection
curation and preservation of born
digital content cut across the full
range of core responsibilities of
libraries but our procedures our
workflows our policies and our
technologies are insufficient to the
tasks of born digital selection
acquisition synthesis navigation
discovery dissemination interpretation
understanding use application and
preservation we failed how do we
confront the conditions of constant
mutation of waves of new applications of
unfriendly public policy of self-imposed
pressures to create the collective
collection of unrealistic and unclear
user and researcher expectations
requirements at the core of born digital
content preservation I believe our four
principles we must hold the content the
repository as archived because we cannot
preserve what we have not collected we
must enable access the repository as
persistence we must secure the content
the archive as curation and we must take
care of the content the repository as
steward new technologies are feeding the
explosion in born digital content each
year educause and the New Media
Consortium publish the horizon report
which documents and describes important
developments some examples from the past
few years I think will illustrate the
symbiosis and demonstrate this explosion
in born digital material just consider
mobile devices and tablets cloud
computing with distributed processing
and applications geo everything
geolocation geo-tagging the personal web
and customized management of online
content linked data connecting and
relating structured information semantic
aware applications that link link
meaning to answers smart objects and
smart spaces that connect information in
the physical world open content with
wide distribution and wide use massive
open online learning experiences
electronic books in the array of
platforms and applications big data and
big science driving new forms of
research information management games as
learning tools with participation and
interaction visualizations that bring
meaning and understanding to data the
challenge of born digital content comes
at the point when libraries are really
confronting some critical trends
we are experiencing rapidly shifting
user behaviors and expectations we are
trying to figure out how to move away
from redundant inefficient we shared
library operations and aging service
paradigms we recognized the need to
achieve scale and network effects
through aggregation in an environment of
advanced open architecture and the
acceleration of collective innovation we
are facing metadata metadata chaos in
terms of its quality its currency and
its accuracy we face a new economic
context and a mandate for systemic
change we are not sure how to deal with
conditions of massive surveillance
security meltdowns threats to network
neutrality and corporate control of the
infrastructures of information discovery
and content how does how just born
digital fit into what libraries do we
support teaching and learning research
and scholarship and community health and
development we respond to a societal and
global mandate we respond in how we will
how our roles and processes will be
extended to embrace born digital content
or will be massive challenges spawn a
new vision a new purpose new methods and
new systems I believe that's what we're
talking about here over the next two
days quality equals content plus
functionality how do we make sure that
the born digital content is preserved
but also remains usable long term that
means that we understand and accommodate
the important characteristics of digital
information accessibility and
availability with no constraints on time
and geography the searchability and
research ability
being able to ask new questions the
currency and real-time nature of this
information its dynamism in fluidity and
link ability the collaborative in
interactive nature of that information
and it's encyclopedic potential but also
its modularity its volatility and its
fragility boring digital resources also
force us to consider the relationship
among form text and function where
content is no longer tied to format we
are encouraged to be more sensitive to
context render ability and versioning
over time we see the inevitable and
format obsolescence the importance of
authenticity and provenance and the role
of standards such as globally unique
identifier the scope depth and the cost
of the threat means that individual
libraries cannot advance born digital
content preservation on their own we
need to radicalize cooperation promoting
new combinations and new public-private
partnerships through national and global
systemic strategies there is an adage
that says every snowflake in an
avalanche pleads not guilty whether it
is the creation of centers of excellence
or new thinking about mass production or
new infrastructures or new initiatives
and programs we must start from a
position of collaboration so as to
maximize quality productivity and
innovation we must pull together the
polycentric nature the distributed
nature of the way born digital materials
are being captured organized and
preserved and build new collaborative
approaches we will not have the
technologies the tools the workflows and
standards
unless we work together in new ways it
will be challenging i also think to
create a robust and successful born
digital content preservation capacity
without new thinking about copyright
libraries are capturing and preserving
digital materials as fair use efforts to
produce new exceptions or limitations in
section 108 of the Copyright Act
something I worked on for three years
for purposes of digital preservation
have not been successful our law is out
of sync with technology and user needs
where does the preservation of born
digital content intersects with orphan
works with transformative use with the
public interest what should be the
relationship between licensing and
copyright limitations what about the
issue of open content and proprietary
rights how do we manage national
copyright provisions in a global
networked environment I attended a few
weeks ago a meeting convened by the IMLS
to look at the questions around the
National digital platform I raised at
that meeting some key questions that we
have formulated over time which really
are challenging us to reserve refresh
our approach our national approach to
this set of issues and here are the
questions that I put on the table how do
we move from scattered institutional
investments and siloed projects to
national and global programs how do we
expand our understanding of digital
content creation at large scale to
create curation discovery use and
preservation of digital content how do
we build tools that are ubiquitous
iterative transparent and integrated how
do we build infrastructure at global
scale and create public-private
partnerships with publishers media
companies search engines social media
importantly with our faculty with our
teachers our researchers and users in
creators of information really to
advance our digital platform objectives
and our library's recruiting developing
and retaining the professional staff who
can lead us in practice and performance
I remind I reminded that audience of
several contexts that I think we need to
always consider the global context how
does our work integrate into an
international venue the policy context
where licensing so often displaces the
public law of copyright how do we build
user supportive policy the diversity
context how do we make sure that what
we're preserving is not just the winners
and the information that traditionally
has survived but how do we use us as a
new model for participation why
participation in the discussion but also
affirmative inclusion of diverse
perspectives and diverse content in what
is preserved how do we understand users
particularly the teaching learning
context as more and more of this content
is integrated into the classrooms both
virtual and physical where does
scholarly communication fit what's the
context of the integration of this stuff
into the way scholars gather present
their ideas and archive that information
how do we move from kumbaya to a period
of more polygamy to a period of more
radical collaboration and where is the
national leadership what is the role of
the Library of Congress what is the role
of the National Archives what is the
role of OCLC what is the role of a la I
think knees national professional
organizations need to set up step up in
far more rigorous ways to build the type
of national and global conversation and
capability to get the job done
how many libraries have well-developed
plans for born digital content capture
description and preservation how many
institutions have put in place the
funding to enable and sustain these
plans how are those agencies and
foundations that fund libraries and
support learning and scholarship
responding to this challenge do we truly
understand user expectations for digital
content and how it will be used what
digital content has persistent value and
how will we make sound conditions on
what to collect and to preserve how old
persistence and quality be insured how
will collaborative efforts be structured
and good governance and sustainability
of sustainability purrs be preserved and
insured what is needed for operational
organizational and architectural
scalability it is I will argue our
predetermined role in the Academy in the
library community it is our role our
fate and I would argue our destiny to
serve society's interest and to take on
the full responsibility through the
collective library and the collective
University for the preservation of born
digital content I hope these remarks
were interesting and provocative and
give you a context to talk about these
issues over the course of the next two
days thank you for this opportunity
bob says I should take questions
Jim so at the IMLS meeting around the
ideas around digital platform did this I
did this sort of sense more come up
around the in collaborating in doing
something like web archiving to address
these ideas of you know we're in
different sectors a lot of us are in
universities but just that idea of how
can we and is is the government is IMLS
putting funding thinking about this sort
of putting the stuff forward for us to
be able to have something on which we
can build and do our programmatic right
i think it was recognized and embraced
as a key issue a key national priority
brewster kahle was there and so we had
an opportunity to talk about where
Internet Archive fits into this
conversation and this solution I think
there was an effort to talk as I have
tried to do today sort of the born
digital level as opposed to just web
archiving although it's recognized the
IMLS about a year ago and it was a
meeting i participated in raised the
question of whether they should be
funding a lot of interesting projects
and experiments or whether they should
concentrate the resources the limited
resources into major grants for major
infrastructure development and that's
why i think we've seen the grants in the
last round of IMLS they're larger and
they're more directed and they're
looking more at what they're calling the
national digital platform as what
they're choosing to invest in now DPLA
was also there and we raised the issue
of when and how we move and DPLA beyond
the important things that are being done
today in terms of the digitization of
historical content to capturing more of
the born digital materials it was
recognized that the two key points that
I made today public policy particularly
copyright and collaboration we're going
to be critical in order to make those
advances but we also recognize that with
each second of each day of the problem
gets worse and worse and the scenarios
that I outlined become more common
hi Jim um where else have you been
giving this talk uh you need to reach
out you know obviously beyond the choir
have you talked to John Paulson he gave
the Harvard 400 million businesses way
to graduate and he gave it to the School
of Engineering but really I mean it's so
important yeah no I agree I i I've just
been asked I've been participating in a
series of meetings with the social
science research council and one of the
issues I've raised in that context is
this suite of concerns and they've just
asked me this week to join a group that
will focus on this issue within the
context of the social sciences they're
sort of really worried about the
incident in issue of integrity that was
raised by that graduate student in his
PhD dissertation out in California and
so they're starting to connect the dots
of how integrity needs to be more widely
defined and social sciences could be at
risk research in the social sciences
could be at risk if we don't
collectively begin to deal with these
things they they recognize the role of
the library and I've been trying to say
to them as I tried to also suggest here
is that we are part of the solution but
we are not the solution libraries this
has got to be a larger larger public and
scholarly investment that's made to make
this to solve and advance some of these
issues
to agree with everything I said right
all right this was the choir Thank You
Steven we do agree with everything you
said thank you stay close but the
copyright issue ah I mean that you spent
three years on and didn't really succeed
that that's such a blocker for so many
of the things that you just mentioned
and including what's the prospect which
it sits I think we're at risk more than
ever if anyone read the GAO report on
the status of the Copyright Office in LC
one recognizes some of the issues that
we're going to be dealing with over the
next several years a copyright reform is
in the wind but it's not the type of
copyright reform that we probably would
put ourselves behind I think there's
concern that the Copyright Office is
looking to move out at the Library of
Congress and to find a home elsewhere in
the federal infrastructure probably more
aligned with the economic side of the
house commerce side of the house which
to me is a major problem and I think the
types of issues that we raised in the
one the 108 study group document and
report is quite I think innovative and
forward-looking but there was not
agreement among the parties at the table
which included lots of representative
from the content community around these
types of issues of long-term
preservation I don't accept the position
taken by the content community that
don't worry libraries we will take care
of this stuff we know what that means
and we've seen it in terms of our modest
ability of through things like portico
and the continuing centrality importance
of locks clocks in order to capture
material published material but we know
it's it falls far short so if we can't
take care of those of the routine stuff
if I could use that word how are we
going to take care of all this other
stuff which is going to be increasingly
important but i think this we're seeing
in developments at
ypo we're library exceptions and
limitations are on the table and we're
seeing innovations in national copyright
laws in some of the countries around the
world but the fact remains that nearly I
think by kenny's Kenny cruises
estimation over eighty percent of the
world's nations do not have exceptions
or limitations in there look up to write
villa for libraries archives and museums
I knew mentioning locks clocks would
provoke a question no actually I've been
thinking about sameness I'm reminded of
the Pogo quote we have met the enemy and
he is us has that assoc or she and Jim I
remember sitting in your office at
Columbia ten years ago and having a
conversation very much like this and who
are you meeting with you Oh Misha you
with me be with you enjoy and we were
talking about so I was right then
resident were right then and we were
talking about ARL and leadership foreign
digital and preservation and the need
for the libraries to continue to build
collections and take responsibility and
I wonder if you've seen a shift a
positive shift over the last decade to
finally have that finally shows us that
more people are willing to step up I
think I have seen more of a recognition
of the challenge and why it's important
and the complexity of it and I think
when people look at that scale and
complexity they sort of back up and say
oh my goodness this is more than I can
deal with and therefore the
collaborative National systemic if not
global systemic approach is going to be
important national libraries around the
world are taking some responsibility for
domain
preservation I think it's berries in
terms of the rigor and managing for the
mutability of that information but at
least there's some recognition in some
of the countries in the world that an
agency needs to step up and do this on
behalf of a country we don't have that
here Brewster has done a great job in
helping us capture long-term web some
web content but he acknowledges in terms
of how he does it and what he picks up
and when he doesn't pick up in that
effort and it just doesn't get into the
communities the university's the city's
the government's and so forth in ways
that I think are going to be essential
going forward so yes I think it's being
embraced and recognized but I think
we're far far short of the solutions
that we need that's why this meeting is
so important um Jim one more thing and
it's I guess it is pushing back a little
bit maybe on a couple of things that you
said and it's that I think for for good
reasons we keep talking about libraries
and and and in fact there's you know the
archives that are not in libraries
there's all the archives that are doing
born-digital you know archiving
collecting of material that may also
happen to be web-only kinds of
information and so I think that that
idea of the who are we talking about
what is this what is the community what
is the the collaborations and the and
therefore the platforms of also all the
archival communities and and you know
whether that's in private companies and
institutions and in public sector and
private sector non-government that
there's a there's we we also need to be
brought into the table not just to the
exclusion of if we're not in a library
then we're not a part of this and I
think that's an important I agree one
hundred and fifty percent with your
observation I said it's beginning I was
going to use the library lens but for me
library equals lamb libraries archives
and museums cultural organizations I got
beat up on this issue at the IMLS
meeting as well and I sort of hugged the
person virtually and said i 100% agree
with you as well so
my vocabulary needs to change but I
totally embrace the role of the liar the
larger archival community in this effort
but I also recognize the importance of
the scholars the teachers the faculty
the authors who produce this stuff
whatever it might be but individual
authors individual institutions
individual libraries are not going to be
able to solve this problem so absolutely
and that's now on the record again so
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much to you I think that context
and that broader perspective on things
is really going to be helpful as we go
through the day and think about these
things in more detail I will say well
these days when Jim talks about physical
and format obsolescence I'm afraid he's
talking about me but but I like that
good so as we prepare to to move into
the the panel sessions I just want to
say a couple of words about the two
themes that were talking about and how
we why we came up with those themes and
it dates back again to that conference
in 2012 we're two of the findings
conclusions ideas that emerged from that
one was that there's a lot of things
that that the host of things that need
to happen technically to to make web
archiving work better to make it easier
to make the results and then the use of
the the content improve and part of the
grant that we have received from the the
mellon Foundation included seed funding
for what has turned out to be 6
technology development tool development
projects and so one of the main
objectives of the meeting today is to
provide an opportunity for the lead
researchers on those projects to present
their work to an audience like this and
discuss its its significance and what
they've done the other big idea that
came out of that was a recognition that
it libraries and this gets back to some
of the things that Jim was talking about
libraries acting on their own
we are only going to be able to take
this kind of initiative so far and that
we're going to need to collaborate and
build both connections and structures
probably in a variety of different ways
and so the next second theme in the
second present set of presentations
interspersed today our discussions and
presentations on activities that are
already taking place to try to build
these collaborations and on towards the
end of the day on some reflections on
what we may need to do that goes much
further and works on a larger and
broader scale for these things